[Music]
battling to control the inferno across
spain it's a race against time to
contain wildfires that have been raging
out of control
from the south
to the north where blazers have scorched
4 600 hectares of land over the past few
days in the worst wildfires for a decade
in a visit to one of the worst affected
areas spain's prime minister pedro
sanchez made clear what he thought was
to blame
i want to say that evidently climate
change kills
it kills people kills the ecosystem the
biodiversity and it also destroys the
most precious goods of our society which
is affected by these wildfires
homes businesses and livestock
in south west france firefighters were
using every means at their disposal
including controlled burning a tactic
used to clear out the build-up of
flammable materials by igniting the
surrounding vegetation
and it is a matter of urgency since
tuesday the blazers have already
consumed nearly 11 thousand hectares of
forest
and at least sixteen thousand people
residents and tourists alike have been
forced to move to emergency shelters
amid all this is the uncomfortable
reality of the effect of these
record-breaking high temperatures
as delegates from 40 countries gathered
at the petersburg climate dialogue in
berlin
the message from the hosts act now
before it's too late
the immersion we must intensify our
mutual efforts and that's why we in the
german government moved climate foreign
policy to the foreign ministry in order
to contain this century's biggest
security threat on an international
level
a threat that risks spilling out beyond
countries directly affected sony gallego
al jazeera